il ya un adage qui dit mieux vaut tard
que jamais la décision de la maison
michel sarrazin de québec d'offrir
l'aide médicale à mourir a agréablement
surpris le docteur alain nault à son
avis il était temps je me désole
pour tous ces malades qui n'ont pu y
avoir accès à la maison michel sarrazin
le docteur noi prodiguer les médicale à
mourir à de nombreux patients qui
auraient aimé pousser leur dernier
souffle à la maison michel sarrazin mais
qui ont été forcés de le faire à
l'hôpital puisque l'aide médicale à
mourir n'y était pas offert présentement
seuls la moitié des maisons de soins
palliatifs de la province offre cet
ultime recours de fin de vie pour les
défenseurs de l'aide médicale à mourir
il est grand temps que ces
établissements s'adapte on est rendu là
il faut que nos amis d'autres aille
aussi vite que la société s'était rendu
là mais la réflexion n'est pas si simple
pour ces centres qui doivent tenir
compte de l'avis de ceux dont ils
dépendent
prendre le temps de réfléchir avec nos
soignants avec nos bénévoles qui forment
nos équipes avec nos donateurs aussi qui
nous entoure et il faut s'assurer de
notre peau rien brusquer
pour le docteur no la résistance de
certaines maisons de soins palliatifs
tiens justement des convictions de
généreux donateurs doit certainement
aussi question de financement qu'on ne
veut pas perdre des communautés
religieuses
parce que c'est un secret de
polichinelle que les communautés
religieuses en général sont de grands
donateurs
notre mission est d'abord et avant tout
d'accompagner nos patients et si on
reçoit quelqu'un que pour lui donner les
médicaments mourir on n'est que des
exécuteurs certains établissements comme
la maison de soins palliatifs du
littoral à lévis ont choisi un autre 2
il offre l'aide médicale à mourir
seulement aux patients qui sont déjà
hébergées ici trois patients y ont eu
recours dans la dernière année mais ça
pourrait changer la décision de la
maison michel sarrazin une pionnière des
soins palliatifs au québec risque
d'alimenter la réflexion d
bisman encore réfractaires ici camille
carpentier radio canada québec